this episode of real science is brought
to you by skillshare
home to thousands of classes that can
teach you a new life skill
in a year when a single virus has killed
millions
it's hard to think of viruses as
anything other than bad
our understanding of them is largely
based around the death and destruction
they cause
hiv has caused the deaths of over 33
million people since the start of that
epidemic in the 80s
the ebola virus kills up to 90 percent
of people who get infected with it
in a gruesome and awful way polio still
paralyzes people
zika dengue yellow fever still ravage
the tropics
so from where we're standing it very
much seems that viruses are not
our friend there are an estimated
quadrillion quadrillion individual
viruses
10 to the 31st power that exist on this
earth with us
more than all the stars in the universe
but they aren't
all bad only a small few have the
ability to cause us harm
and the vast majority don't affect us at
all but over time
some have become beneficial to us in
fact
a part of us viruses have been infecting
us
and our ancestors for as long as we've
been around
and around a hundred million years ago
our mammalian ancestor was infected with
a virus that would shape the tree of
evolution from that point
on the traces of this infection and many
others
exist as viral fossils within our genome
around eight percent of our dna is not
human at all
but viral and in recent years scientists
have started to see that these viral
gene sequences are not simply leftover
genetic baggage
strange and purposeless but are
sequences that code for essential
proteins in human development
how can it be that our evolution
depended on a virus getting into our
genome
how did these viral segments of dna
become a part of us
and what do they do for us that's so
important
no one knows for sure where viruses came
from whether they existed before
any cells did assembling themselves from
molecules in the environment
or whether they are derived from
cellular life
leaking out of or being reduced from a
cellular existence
but regardless of this chicken and egg
scenario viruses are perfect parasites
they are tiny particles of genetic
material enclosed in a protein coating
and their existence depends on invading
cells to hijack the cellular machinery
to replicate themselves
to invade a cell a virus recognizes and
binds to the cell via a receptor
molecule on the cell surface
and then breaks in once inside the viral
genes are expressed
viral proteins are created and new virus
particles are assembled and are ready to
be released
in some cases the exiting viruses leave
the host cell intact so it can continue
cranking out more
virus particles but sometimes the
viruses cause the host cell to burst
killing it the viruses then float within
the extracellular space
poised to infect more cells this is
likely the story of viral infection that
you've
heard it's the primary mechanism of
spread for most viruses
but some viruses like hiv measles and
the herpes simplex virus
can also spread directly between two
cells that are in contact with each
other in a process called cell to cell
transmission
this is particularly insidious as it
enables viruses to evade the body's
immune response
viruses that can spread in this way have
a few mechanisms to achieve it
perhaps most notably genes that code for
proteins
that force host cells to fuse together
allowing the viruses to jump from cell
to cell
and these genes that seem absolutely
harmful to human kind by allowing some
viruses to wreak havoc on our bodies
have also enabled us to exist at all
when these particular genes got inserted
into our ancestors genomes a hundred
million years ago
the course of human evolution was
changed forever
the human genome contains around a
hundred thousand fragments of viral dna
and the story of how it got there begins
with retroviruses
retroviruses are viruses that have an
rna genome
and work backwards from how other
viruses work
instead of using dna to make rna which
is then used to make viral proteins
retroviruses insert rna to make dna
using reverse transcriptase this dna
then makes its way to the nucleus and
inserts itself into the host cell's dna
thus changing the genome of the host
cell
hiv for example is a retrovirus that
incorporates itself into the genome of a
cell
where it lives as a template for
creating more hiv viruses
the hiv virus infects immune cells but
some viruses infect the cells that will
be passed through the generations
and this is where our history with viral
genes begins
if retroviruses infect reproductive
cells
the cells that produce eggs or sperm the
virus inserts its dna
into the heritable genome of the host
once a retrovirus has embedded itself in
this way
it's known as an endogenous retrovirus
at first endogenous retroviruses force
cells to make more retroviruses
that can infect other cells but over the
generations
the viral dna mutates and endogenous
retroviruses eventually lose the ability
to infect new cells
much of the viral dna within our genomes
is therefore
thought to be dormant evidence of our
ancestors past
infections but nothing that affects us
now
but for some endogenous retroviruses the
story is more complicated
scientists have realized that even after
being disabled and no longer being able
to fully replicate itself
some retrovirus sequences can still make
some of their proteins
and over time two of these viral
proteins became essential in human
development
evolution co-opting viral genes for
human
needs
[Music]
in human pregnancy there are many
biological marvels
and the placenta is at the front of that
list
it's an organ that develops in the
uterus during pregnancy
and provides oxygen and nutrients to the
growing baby
and removes waste products from the
baby's blood
the placenta attaches to the wall of the
uterus and is where the baby's umbilical
cord arises from
and it may have never developed without
the help of viral proteins
since sit in one and since sit in two
around five days
after fertilization the embryo has
differentiated into two distinct cell
types
the inner cell mass which will develop
into the fetus and eventually become
the baby and trophoblasts which will
develop into the placenta
and external membranes around the
seventh day
the blastocyst starts to implant onto
the uterine wall
where it will remain attached until
birth at this point
the syncytiotrophoblast starts to form
around the developing placenta
it's a structure that determines which
substances cross the placenta
such as nutrients and oxygen and which
substances do not
such as certain maternal hormones and
toxins
it's both life-giving and protective and
is the structure that results
from the once viral synthetic proteins
in viruses the syncident proteins allow
them to fuse host cells together
so they can spread from one cell to
another in the cell to cell viral
transmission i mentioned before
now the proteins allow placental cells
to fuse together to form this vital
layer
next to the uterus without syncidin
the placenta does not form correctly and
if it had never been introduced into the
human gene pool
the placenta would not have evolved as
it is today
without it internal pregnancy would have
developed
very differently or perhaps not at all
viral sequences that live in our genome
act as raw
material for new adaptations lines of
code that should be useless to us
turned into something valuable in what
feels like a miraculous turn of events
it reminds us that evolution has no plan
there is no single track on which it
operates
it's a machine of randomness and
variability
and in all likelihood our history of
past retroviral infections
and even current ones will continue to
shape our
evolution as a species behind the scenes
at real science and real engineering we
are
constantly trying to improve our
creativity and workflow to bring you all
better and better videos
i am personally bad at multitasking and
juggling several different projects at
once
to help deal with this challenge i turn
to our friend and fellow youtuber thomas
frank's productivity class on skillshare
called productivity masterclass create a
custom system that works
this class helps you create a task
management system that you'll actually
stick to
it taught me how to manage our calendars
better and set up a task management
system that i now use religiously
and as our team grows we've also been
expanding our animation capabilities
with more and more 3d animations made in
blender and cinema 4d
with still plenty of 2d and character
animations too
skillshare has fantastic courses in
multiple animation platforms
like blender and after effects when i
started making videos
i didn't know how to animate like at all
thinking the software was too
intimidating but once you dive in you
realize it's not as hard as you thought
especially with the classes skillshare
has
right now i'm working on honing in my
skills with this class called animating
with ease in after effects
which is teaching me how to use
keyframes to their maximum potential
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no distracting ads
and it's less than ten dollars a month
with an annual subscription
but the first thousand people to sign up
with the link in the description will
get a free trial of skillshare premium
so there's no risk in trying it out and
looking for a class that piques your
interest
as always thanks for watching and if
you'd like to see more from me
the links to my twitter instagram and
patreon are below
you